this week on wheel of science we're
talking isaac newton
the gravity of this subject cannot be
measured good one chuck
welcome to wheel of science
what's up everybody and welcome to wheel
of science i'm your host chuck nice and
this
is the show where we answer your
questions about the universe
but i don't answer your questions about
the universe the one the only dr neil
degrasse tyson
answers your questions about the
universe what's up little newbie
you know me and newton go way back so
just get on and spin that wheel
[Music]
patrick o'leary wants to know this what
would isaac newton's first
google search be
how about uh what is google
dude doesn't know anything yet or what
is computer
i have no idea chuck i can't believe it
that is the first time
that a no idea has come up in all the
years i have been working
with you but if you had to choose one
thing what would it be neil all right if
you have to ask
one question maybe it would be
which kind of apple hurts the least when
it falls from a tree
and hits you in the head chuck
well it's not that one and i thought
that story was
fake well he did sit under a tree and
watch an apple fall but no he was not
hitting the head by the apple that was
at another tree
neil you ready for another question
chuck spin the wheel
[Music]
rex young wants to know this if newton
never existed
and his work never replicated by anyone
else
ever how different would our world
be oh we would not have the industrial
revolution
we would still be with horse and buggy
he laid the foundation of
all major science that would follow in
the 150 years
after so but the good thing about
science
is that as brilliant as he was all that
would have still been discovered
given some time that followed it maybe
not by the same person
because his titanic genius did it all
spread it share the love 50 people
perhaps
50 different physicists would have
eventually come up with all of his laws
and all of his ideas so uh
we're in good hands with the methods and
tools of science
and those who invoke them to decode the
universe
well neil in my little fan girl world
you would have either come up with it
yourself
or been one of those 50 scientists don't
say anything
you ready for another question all right
let's do this
[Music]
marcos steven juarez wants to know if
newton came to visit us
what major problem on the edge of modern
physics will you present him with
first i wouldn't present them physics
problems first
i present them our societal problems
first i'd say can you fix this
any way to fix climate change fix
our energy problem because he's a really
brilliant guy and if you lay out the
elements of a problem
he might come to a solution that none of
us would have even dreamt of
so at first do that then i would bring
the physics
problems to him can you help us with
dark matter dark energy
what was around before the universe
began uh how did
we go from from organic molecules to
self-replicating life in the early earth
i would hand them the biggest questions
we have and sit back and wait for an
answer because none of us could do it
well which one do you think he could
solve
first i think the dark matter problem
the fact that 85 percent of the gravity
of the universe has no known origin
and he's a gravity guy i think he would
like choose that problem first
when given the option ah the gravity
expert solving the gravity problem
i see what you did there neal all right
time to take a break but we'll be back
with more questions on wheel of
science it doesn't take isaac newton to
build a kick butt
website i'm not even joking i did it for
wheel of science on wix
and look how great it looks we embedded
every episode on wheel of science.com
added the descriptions customize the
template to look professional and
now it's on the web for all of you to
see oh that's nice
i like it time to create your own site
head to the link in the description and
check out wix
that's wix.com go star talk
welcome back to wheel of science time
for another question let's get this
party started
[Music]
jack garrison says this why did newton
need to invent
calculus what problem was he trying to
solve
that he could not solve without calculus
newton basically on a dare invented
integral and differential calculus
so those of you who have taken calculus
in high school or in college
slogging through it newton invented it
on a lark
there's a friend of his who asked him
why is it that planets orbit
in these shapes called ellipses why
that shape and not some other shape
because the these these shapes come out
of his his theories of gravity
he said i don't know i'll get back to
you goes away comes back
here's why these are actually sections
of a cone
if you take a perfect cone and cut it
horizontally and look at
that's a perfect circle cut it at an
angle
that's an ellipse cut it at an angle
parallel to the side of the cone
you get what we call a parabola cut it
at a higher angle you get a hyperbola
and so all gravitational orbits have
one of these three shapes and of course
the last two don't orbit at all
they're open-ended orbits once they come
in they never come back
they come in exit they're gone forever
so
to understand why gravity
describes conical sections
these shapes required calculus and so we
invented that
to answer the question his friend posed
what have you invented lately oh i
invented a time travel machine
it doesn't work but i invented it plus
since you've been talking about cones
all i've been doing is standing here
taking the ice cream
you ready for another question neil spin
the wheel
[Music]
elaine cass wants to know this some
parts of newton's work
have been superseded by einsteins
how is newton's work still useful in the
sciences
and engineering great question so
you can say superseded but it's not
entirely accurate
the better way to think about it is
isaac newton's laws of gravity and
motion
apply to every kind of motion he had
seen
you know a fast running horse
the moon orbit around earth earth orbit
around the sun
and only when you get to really high
speeds really strong gravities do you
find
that newton's laws break down they no
longer describe nature
accurately and you needed einstein's
equations
of motion einstein's special theory of
relativity
that's his his theory of motion and
einstein's general theory of relativity
that's the theory of the modern theory
of gravity and what you find
is that here's this pocket of the
universe described by
isaac newton and einstein's theories
describe
a bigger sampling of the universe
and within which you find
newton's laws so no it didn't supplant
newton
it enclosed newton in a bigger deeper
understanding of the universe
we went to the moon using just newton's
laws they were sufficient
but you want to probe the atom you want
to probe the early universe the big bang
itself
you need einstein well there you have it
einstein and newton
two great minds that taste great
together
that's like a zombie's dream all right
time for this week's caption contest but
this week neil
something different happened and i'm not
sure how normally there's a picture of
you
but they turned the tables on me and now
they used a picture of me it's about
time
tired of looking at pictures of myself
and the winning caption is
austin fogelquist who says i think i'm
being paid to be funny
i am being paid right neal neil come on
man
help a brother out yes chuck you are
paid
without love you know i was hoping for
something a little less deep than love
and a little more usable
what the time now for this week's poll
make sure you answer the poll right here
and the question is who would you rather
meet newton
einstein or galileo oh that's got to be
a tough one for you neil
i have an isaac newton finger puppet so
the answer is clear and and
wait there nia where you going where are
you going
[Music]
okay um i'm not sure what's happening
here
like i said me and ike go way back
all right neil um i'm pretty sure that
was the creepiest fan tribute i've ever
seen
there you have it that's our show and of
course we have to thank the one the only
dr neil degrasse tyson thanks neil
i am delighted to be your personal
astrophysicist
and of course in whatever else you may
be doing on december 25th
don't forget to bid happy birthday two
isaac newton hey i suck at calculus
but that's okay it's not a requirement
to make a beautiful website on wix
it takes just minutes to get your
website up and running using their
artificial design intelligence known as
adi
i don't know how it works i just know it
makes everything
happen and happen beautifully if you
want something a little more custom you
can head into their drag and drop editor
to get exactly the sight you had in mind
what are you waiting for
start your site right now with wix find
the link
in the description go to wix.com go
slash star talk
[Music]